How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. Here we are going to
talk about trading the invalidation of
my bias. You have heard me talk a lot
about candle two or candle three
closures and having that daily bias. But
how do we actually trade that bias if
the bias is wrong? And that is what we
are going to talk about in today's
video. So in this video we are going to
pretend like we have a daily bullish
bias and that is what we're going to go
into each of these examples and then
understand the invalidations that can
occur. Now within my model, I only
approach invalidations of my bias in two
ways. That would be an opposing setup
that forms or the invalidation of the
EQ. Any other way that a invalidation
forms, I'm not interested in trading the
other way. These are the only two
scenarios. So here you can see we have
the anticipation for a bullish bias up
and through previous day as we expect a
continuation.
But what happens? Price opens,
immediately trades higher into that
previous day high and then forms a
reaction. We are manipulating off of
this high or forming a reversal. If that
is confirmed on the lower time frame,
then I can look to trade this back into
the range or to the other side of the
range depending on how large this wick
is. If we have a small wick that
supports expansion to this current low
or if we have a large wick, I'm looking
back in towards the opening price or the
EQ of the previous candle.
Now the other way I invalidate a trade
is if price is closing below on the
aligned time frame, the EQ of our
previous candle. So here you can see
price opens, has a shallow wick which
supports expansion lower and then is
trading below the EQ of this higher time
frame candle and closing below it on the
lower time frame.
Let's go take a look at this with a
lower time frame picture. So here we're
going to take a look at the invalidation
of the EQ. So here you can see we have a
bullish trend. We're going into the next
day bullish. Price opens, makes a high,
a change in the state of delivery, but
most importantly phases a price around
that EQ. We have expansion below the EQ
and then what? We retrace back up and
what do we do? We have a retracement
into a fair value gap and we're looking
like we're going to trade lower, right?
So this is an invalidation of a setup
because of how price traded. Right, we
have a reversal at this high here,
expansion, retracement and we're
invalidating that EQ. So what can I do?
I can look in that area there and look
for a continuation lower. Looking for
candle two or candle three closures and
looking to trade that lower. Now the
other way I invalidate a bias is that a
opposing formation, right? So this would
be a candle two forming against me. So
you can see that's generally when we
open up near our previous day high or
previous day low. Here we open up, sweep
that previous day high out, we have a
change in the state of delivery and I
can be looking for that move back lower,
back to liquidity resting inside that
previous day's range or the previous day
low depending on the size of the wick.
So what am I going to do here? Once that
opposing setup has formed or that change
in the state of delivery, then I would
seek a continuation or a candle two or
candle three closure looking to trade
that the other way. Now just to review,
those are the only two types of
invalidations that I will look to trade.
Price can consolidate and invalidate my
bias, but those do not set up trades in
the opposite direction. These are the
only ways that I'll look to trade and
once again, that is an opposing setup
that will form, which is candle two
forming in the other direction or the
invalidation of an EQ, which is really
just the setup is failing and I can
anticipate it to trade the other way. So
let's get into TradingView and go over
few examples of this. So, here we are in
our first example and you can see we
have taken out a relevant low here on
the daily time frame, as well as forming
a candle two closure with a very strong
bullish closure. We're going to the
hourly time frame.
We have a change in the state of
delivery. It's valid to be looking for
an upside move in this following day.
You can see we print this T spot here
and then we're forming a continuation to
go higher. Now, let's see if we can get
this move higher.
And you can see we are really struggling
to form any sort of bullish expansion
here. We have a continuation right here.
Which should hold price if we are going
to trend higher. But, what do we notice
about this continuation as we zoom in?
It is getting disrespected.
So, now not only do we have a bearish
change in the state of delivery with SMT
off of previous day high, but we're also
invalidating this continuation where we
should not see price return to if we're
going to remain in a bullish trend. So,
now it's safe to say that we have formed
what? A reversal off of a previous day
high. So, instead of price opening up
and forming a low or the wick of the
daily candle to then trade higher, we
are opening high first. So, what we can
do is get a better look is go to the
30-minute time frame around open. So,
down here on the 30-minute time frame,
what do we notice about our daily
candle? We did have that open high
first, which is a bearish sign. We have
a 30-minute change in the state of
delivery right here.
Now, we have taken out the short-term
low. We want to see the reaction we get
here, but it's important to note what
else? We have a candle two closure on
the 4-hour here, which says if we were
going to get a candle three
continuation, we can get that or open.
So, what do we notice?
We trade higher. Are we still respecting
this area? Yes, but we would need some
bearish price action or a new
continuation to trust this.
And what do we notice after this close?
We have formed a new continuation here
on the 30.
So, going into the open, it's reasonable
to expect that because of the hourly
time frame, we have what? We have formed
a SMT off this previous day high, as
well as a new continuation on the 30
minute. We could look to see this trade
lower. We could look to take an entry
here, put our stop on this high, and
then look back into the range. Now, what
did we learn about in the PDF in terms
of targets? So, let's go to the hourly
time frame here.
In terms of targets, what can we be
targeting? We can look back to the EQ or
to the previous day low. So, that could
be our targets. So, let's see how that
works out.
You can see, we do hit that EQ, and then
we go ahead and we're reaching for that
previous day low. And that's where we
are at currently. But, just to review,
if we're going to have an invalidation
of a daily framework, it's either going
to occur by invalidating the EQ or a
reversal forming off previous day high,
or essentially a candle two in the
opposing direction. So, you see how we
are forming this candle two in the
opposite direction. Generally, I want to
see that paired with an SMT or some sort
of continuation. So, at the time, we did
have an SMT with YM. YM ran higher, so
we formed an SMT here.
But, we have a continuation entry that
provides a framework to trade that
invalidation. So, even if I'm trading a
reversal or an invalidation, I'm still
looking for a continuation.
Let's get into another example. So, here
we are in our next example, and what do
we have? We have a candle two closure
here, as well as that is paired with an
SMT off of this low. So, it would be
valid to be looking for price to trade
higher in this following day.
Let's go down to the hourly time frame.
You can see, we have a nice V-shaped
reversal here, so we could be looking
for price to trade higher, as long as we
run out this consolidation low, and then
trade through the highs. Let's see what
happens.
You can see we do reach into this low,
into this fair value gap, and then we
are looking for a continuation
over this level here. Now, what do we
notice about this continuation? It's
taking so long to form that that this is
just becoming a consolidation.
Let's see how we trade around this
previous day high.
Here you can see we reach into that
previous day high. We want to look at
the phases of price here because this is
where we would form an invalidation if
it's going to occur.
What do we have on this next candle? We
have an SMT and a change in the state of
delivery off of the previous day high.
Now you see how we are forming
accumulation, manipulation, and we can
see a distribution lower. Now the whole
idea behind an invalidation trade within
the fractal model is if we're not going
to form a swing point and trade higher,
well then what is going to fail? This
swing is going to fail. And if that
swing fails, we now have candle two's
low as our draw on liquidity.
Now we have a change in the state of
delivery. We can anticipate a price to
move lower here. We can either trade
this reversal here, or what else can we
do? We can look for a continuation to
form as well.
And it's quite choppy in there, but we
do get a move lower to that drawn
liquidity.
So just to review, if we are looking to
trade a invalidation trade, we have to
one have a proper framework or a proper
setup that then fails. And by fails, it
either forms an opposing setup off a
previous day high or low, or it is
disrespecting the EQ.
So you notice we have that step one. We
form that reversal off previous day
high. And then it also helps that we get
the closure below the EQ signaling for a
continuation lower into this low. So
here we are in our next example, and we
are on gasoline futures. You can see we
have a nice V-shape reversal with a
candle two closure on the daily. Looking
into this next candle, if we're looking
for a continuation higher, what do we
want to see? Open low into this area, a
continuation to form into trade higher
into the failure swings above. Let's see
what happens.
You notice, we're not respecting this
EQ. Now, we can still get a bullish
reaction out of it, and EQ does not mean
it's automatically going to fail, right?
It just means that it's unlikely to
expand, or we need to see more
confirmation pretty quickly. Let's see
what happens.
You can see we're just failing to form
any reaction or continuation out of this
area. And now we're forming a bearish
setup. So, what are we seeing? We're
forming bearish opposing candles, and
we're closing below the EQ, which means
we're likely to reach for this previous
day low.
What do we see? We form another
continuation, in which case we could
look to get on side, and then we go
ahead and run out that low.
So, this is an example of where we don't
take out our previous day high, but we
just disrespect and never form a bullish
continuation, which sets up a bearish
framework to trade this into that candle
to low. So, here we are in our next
example, and what do we have? We have a
nice V-shape reversal, a very strong
close into the highs, and a bullish
candle to closure on the daily. So, what
would we want to see? We would want to
see price open, trade lower into a point
of interest, which we have a nice fair
value gap right here, respect the EQ,
and trade higher. Let's see what
happens.
Here you can see we're in that point of
interest. Let's see if we can get a
reaction out of here to form a
continuation.
And you can see we are consolidating.
That does not look good for a reversal
to continue higher here. And now you can
see we are getting a very aggressive
closure below the EQ. Now, once again,
it doesn't mean that price can't reverse
here and then trade higher. It's just
once price reaches beyond that EQ, it's
not a small wick anymore mechanically.
It's less likely to expand. So, for
instance, if we form a low here, price
can expand higher.
If we went ahead and formed a low here,
then we're kind of fighting that daily
candle to get back towards the daily
open and the liquidity around it. But,
generally I prefer to trade the
continuations though. So, let's see if
we can see where this is going to go.
Well, it expands, disrespects this. Does
it get bought back up? No. So, we can
anticipate a continuation lower into
where? That candle two low.
And there you can see we get a failed
candle two because we can't form a
bullish setup and thus it is just a
bearish setup. So, for our next example,
we're going to go back one day. And what
do we notice? We have a candle two
closure and we do get a continuation
into this previous day low.
Now, what do we notice about this
previous day low? We get a nice V-shape
reaction. So, we're forming a reversal
candle here. Now, if we're going to form
a reversal above this previous low,
where could we look for price to trade
back to? The EQ. And does it do that?
It does, right? Now, we're closing over
the EQ, we're disrespecting it. So, we
could look for price to trade to this
swing high. Now, like I said, this isn't
a 100% thing. You can see we're not
always going to reach for that previous
high, especially if a correlated asset
like dollar here on USD/JPY takes it
out. So, just because you see a closure
through the EQ or an invalidation trade
occurring, doesn't mean it's always
going to go hit the targets, right? You
have to have that discernment. Although
most of these examples have been on the
daily time frame, this is a fractal
concept as my fractal model is. So, here
you can see we have expansion, a
consolidation, we run out the low with a
candle two closure. So, we could be
looking higher in this next month. Let's
go down to the daily time frame. So,
here we are on the daily time frame, we
have that confirmation.
As we let this play ahead, where would
we want to see price react from? Well,
we didn't get a very strong closure. So,
we need price to react or run out of
this low into a fair value gap, right?
And then start to trade higher here. So,
this is really our one opportunity for
price to trade higher here. Let's see
what happens.
You can see we immediately disrespect
that and then close below. Closing below
the EQ here means that we could be
looking for price to go where? To fail
or to reach for these lows. Now, it's
not always going to occur. We have to
watch the phases of price. If this gets
bought back up, it can go higher once
again, right? It's not an all or nothing
thing.
Let's see what happens. We do get that
continuation into that low. I hope you
learned something from this video. If
you did, please consider liking and
subscribing. And just in summary, you
need to have a valid fractal model to
then have an invalidation. You can't
just trade an invalidation without a
model forming. So, don't try to just
pattern trade this. Use some context,
use some higher time frame trend, and be
safe. Have a good one.